hammer
okay no I hate to ruin a fun scene and
this is a pretty fun scene but no F-14
Tomcat had dual controls
1986 Top Gun is released
1992 A Few Good Men
and in 1995 Paramount Network television
releases Jag Windows 95
the more sophisticated bells and whistle
sauce Jag was a pretty successful show
it went on for like 10 seasons I think
227 episodes order your box set of 10
seasons of 227 it also spawned a hit
series NCIS and from there we got
endless spin-offs of NCIS Los Angeles
NCIS New Orleans NCIS Naples and CIS
Hawaii and NCIS Sydney in fact there are
so many spin-offs of NCIS that I just
made one up in the middle of that list
and you probably didn't notice and if
you did notice because you're some kind
of NCIS Super Fan your first thought
probably was oh my God how can I watch
NCIS Naples seek therapy the franchise
isn't that great but Jag was the
original it followed the improbable
Adventures of a bunch of Navy lawyers
and one Marine lawyer thrown in for good
measure and since I was once a marine
lawyer let's react to the pilot episode
of Jag together
foreign
[Music]
this is recycled footage from Top Gun
and it's pretty awesome but this time at
least they identify the enemy aircraft
as mig-21s which actually are a real
type of MiG unlike Top Guns mig-29s
which were not God damn we also have an
identifiable enemy the serbs this
episode was filmed at the tail end of
the Bosnian War unfortunately because
we're reusing Top Gun footage we're
still getting repainted American F5s
yeah I'm okay why wouldn't I be we
certainly don't seem like the person
just made the cover-up Time Magazine the
time I thought it was Playboy
nice
such a jerk I think that's more like it
okay so sexism in the military is a
constant theme in this episode this
episode was filmed in 1995. women had
slowly been integrated more fully into
the military over the preceding few
decades but only four years earlier in
July of 1991 did the US government end
its ban on women flying in combat
missions
tail hook which is mentioned later in
the episode was a major Scandal that
happened in the late 1991. basically a
bunch of Navy and Marine Corps aviators
went to a convention put on by the tail
hook Association in Las Vegas
mostly men they engaged in really vile
drunken Behavior towards women from
sexual harassment to outright sexual
assault
the investigation received significant
press coverage and resulted in
substantial administrative punishments
for many of those involved but no
criminal punishments
in the shadow of tail hook in April of
1993 the Secretary of Defense ended the
ban on women serving in combat ships
including aircraft carriers so in this
episode aired in 1995 a woman flying in
an F-14 off a carrier deck for combat
service had only been possible for two
years
[Music]
oh God I need you to
know
yeah so dating aboard a ship is allowed
as long as it doesn't violate the rules
on fraternization
understood anyone who has spent any time
on a ship though knows that that rule
gets violated a fair amount don't tell
Mom
if you found out chances are you'll be
administratively punished and may be
sent home from the ship part of that
whole thing about no hanky-panky if you
are going to do it you want to do it in
somewhere very secret not just making
out on the flight deck that's uh I was
stupid
I have to point this out in the
background an f-14's engines are just
like straight up on fire uh and I know
that this is probably Hollywood trying
to make this look pretty cool and like
it's the active Flight Deck but they're
on fire and while that might be really
good for mood lighting and stuff it's
bad for everyone's safety on that flight
deck
[Music]
and you want to bet
what
nothing
[Music]
foreign
was talking about sir
she disappeared to see last night
I think we can lay this off on NIS I
want a junior officer so that the
Seahawks Skipper isn't intimidated by
the investigation
you're sure you want to trust this to a
junior officer sir
a small mistake it's not a big deal but
this episode was released in 1995. by
then the NIS or Naval investigative
service didn't exist after significant
criticism of how NIS performed after the
tail Hook scandal in 91 NIS was renamed
NCIS the naval criminal investigative
service and reorganized to become a
mostly civilian agency you'd think that
the Jag the actual head of the Navy Jag
Corps would know this but let's take a
step back for a second
why is the Navy Jag sending two Junior
officers to investigate a murder first
the Navy Jag doesn't have the authority
to send investigators if an
investigation into a missing person on a
ship needs to happen the commander of
the ship or the fleet commander would
appoint an investigator for that purpose
second a murder investigation is ncis's
bailiwick now you might argue that while
we Watchers know that it's murder the
characters don't well yes and no I think
it's fair to assume that the second
document That Jag gets is spoiler alert
the anonymous message saying she was
murdered that's why he doesn't give the
investigation to NCIS the scandal of
having a now famous female Aviator
getting murdered that would look bad
[Music]
what's up
that's why we don't wear covers on a
flight deck the cover goes flying get
sucked into a jet engine and suddenly a
multi-million dollar aircraft is
destroyed welcome to the carrier man
thank you
foreign
Rob and presumably Lieutenant Pike were
just at the French Embassy party and
that's why they're wearing their dress
whites but
come on we clearly overdressed they
would have taken a minute to change I
guess you made a promise you can't keep
Lieutenant it's in the Navy's interest
to keep it sir that may be but I'm not
going to overrule The Keg especially
when I agree with him
with all due respect sir I'm in charge
of a possible murder investigation which
gives me the latitude to authorize those
rides those are my men what so Rob knows
that this is possibly a murder and
somehow that gives him the authority to
come into your aircraft operating in a
combat zone if I had known that when I
was in the service I would have had way
more fun did you lose a woman at Sea and
they called me to the White House
anything new from Lieutenant RAB uh not
much sir he still doesn't know whether
it was an accident murder or suicide I
don't want to hear suicide or murder no
sir unless he has insurmountable proof
to the contrary I want a finding of
accidental death okay so this just
confirms what RAB and Pike are up to
that the Navy Jag has them doing what's
called a command investigation or that's
what it seems like the Admiral wants a
finding of accidental death because it's
the most politically expedient suicide
is the preferred explanation for the KAG
and others who think women can't handle
combat roles and murder is the preferred
explanation for lieutenant Pike and
Lieutenant painter who well I want the
truth generally speaking there are three
kinds of real administrative
investigations in the Navy a command
investigation a board of inquiry and a
court of inquiry command investigations
are for the less serious events boards
and courts of inquiry on the other hand
are for major incidents and before I see
it in the comments there are other kinds
of Investigations as well but we're just
not going to get into it right now it's
it's Way Beyond the scope needless to
say a single missing person on a boat is
not a major incident even a single
murder technically isn't now these
investigations are for administrative
fact-finding not determining criminal
guilt or innocence they focus on what
happened who might be responsible what
disciplinary actions should be taken and
how to avoid similar incidents in the
future
command investigations are by far the
most common and navy lieutenants or
Marine captains are frequently appointed
to lead them they are after all the most
utterly disposable cogs in the
commissioned officer machine but let's
be very clear if there is any suspicion
of murder the investigation should and
would be passed off to NCIS we need to
hand this off to NCIS that's why the
agency exists
don't worry Teddy Junior officers get
thrown to the Sharks first
this is 100 True Junior officers are
frequently the ones who get thrown under
the bus and that's just the price of
doing business he's used to losing men
in action not a woman's suicide
how do you know suicide sir
you don't stroll off a flight deck
Lieutenant even at night too many safety
nets you have to jump
or be thrown off
no member of this crew threw a woman
overboard Lieutenant with all due
respect to your opinion sir there are
over 5 000 men on board she committed
suicide was she depressed sir
I'm not a damn shrink lieutenant she was
your Rio and an officer under your
command sir surely you must have an
opinion as to her mental state whatever
that is Lieutenant I do not intend to
discuss it on an open Bridge well then
where and when sir at my damn
convenience and wherever I damn well
please sir we have to recommend to a
board of inquiry what we can Pike The
Keg has said he will be interviewed at
his convenience
so Lieutenant Pike says they have to
recommend to a board of inquiry what
they feel and then gets cut off
so I guess they're not conducting a
command investigation they're
investigating on behalf of a board of
inquiry which isn't really a thing
who the hell sent for us
Admiral Bravo yes ma'am this way sir the
first lady is anxious to hear about your
Seahawk investigation
so it's 1995 obligatory Hillary Clinton
Cameo
well hell Lieutenant why have lsos at
all we may as well say the Navy the
money put these men back in the cockpit
where they'd rather be anyway
Lieutenant you have the worst trap
record on this ship I'm not sure you
could land a tomcat at Dulles without a
wave off sir if you ever ignore an lso
again your next flight will be a one-way
trip on the Cod to Naples yes sir
dismissed
technically by disregarding the lso's
order to wave off she committed a bunch
of crimes some of which could
theoretically carry very long prison
senses but she's just getting a Stern
talking to and that's typical even
though military laws can carry Hefty
theoretical punishments they're usually
dealt with at much much lower levels you
don't like female Pilots do you son
no sir I do not
neither do I
but if one of my lsos ever intentionally
waved a pilot off because she wasn't
female I'd kill hauling
we understand each other Mister even
though the CAG is kind of a sexist
misogynist himself that's uh
better than nothing if you write this up
as a suicide I'll submit a dissenting
position you can't we're not a board of
inquiry we're a two-man team and the
senior member writes the findings so
that's right they're not a board of
inquiry but earlier they implied that
they were acting as investigators for a
board of inquiry sir we have to
recommend to a board of increw and now
RAB is saying that he's the senior
member of a team and the senior man
writes the findings so that strongly
implies that the two of them are
conducting a command investigation it's
unusual for multiple officers to be
appointed to conduct a command
investigation but the rules allow for it
if necessary but it's just this is very
confusing a board of inquiry is a much
more formal process I mean imagine a
bunch of people who are sitting there
taking evidence in a very formal context
at night it's tied down after number
three elevator
we used to go there to be alone
you were her lover
no ma'am
that was her husband
okay well that's a bombshell uh but it's
hard to say that that's actually a crime
so the Navy doesn't deploy married
service members aboard the same ship it
can present some weird Dynamics on board
a ship
so by staying quiet they deploy together
that said there is an affirmative
obligation to tell the government about
your marital status because it affects
your pay and your benefits sometimes
there are obligations where failure to
comply with those obligations isn't a
crime it's just a No-No an
administrative No-No
but there was no ladder of resignation
in her computer yes there was I missed
it the first time she deleted it after
talking to painter deleting erases the
file so that it can be accessed but the
data stays in the memory bank until it's
written over it took me some time but
how did I get out you are never going to
use my computer again
Angela changed her mind about quitting
now you don't do that and then commit
suicide I agree here are the uniforms
you wanted you agree she didn't commit
suicide the odd times he revealed
abrasions on her fingertips
looks like she slipped grabbed the edge
of the deck as she went over I think
we've got an accidental death here Kate
unless she was pushed I who
The Keg okay so they've ruled out
suicide Rob is still going for his
Admiral's preference which is accidental
death while Lieutenant Pike is still
gunning for murder I appreciate her
correcting Rob's grammar too I just have
to say
whom
I didn't murder Angela so I'm not afraid
to face a board of inquiry it's gonna
have to wait settlement is there's a
mission coming up
okay wait a second so there is a board
of inquiry and it's tomorrow at 1300 in
Naples so what are lieutenants Rob and
Pike doing what is their job are they
working for a board of inquiry or are
they doing a command investigation or
are they doing something else entirely
which is really what I'm leaning towards
this is just some complete hollywood-ism
they're on their own they're
investigators for fun well what do you
do
you read a question certain officers
under oath who may be able to shed light
on lieutenant or Rudy's disappearance
ah wait a second now Rob is making it
sound like the skipper should convene a
board of inquiry rather than the fact
that there actually is one scheduled for
tomorrow afternoon if there is in fact a
board of inquiry scheduled for the next
day the skipper would know about it I
this is frustrating I'm confused I don't
like it
hammer
okay now no hey I I hate to ruin a fun
scene and this is a pretty fun scene
but no F-14 Tomcat had dual controls the
radio intercept operator in the back
seat couldn't take the stick the best
bet for the Rio would be to eject both
seats and just hope for the best for
both of them
[Music]
okay so hey fun fact any commissioned
officer can arrest anyone else in the
military as long as they have probable
cause to believe the person has
committed a crime punishable by
court-martial in this case article 118
which is murder so every officer is a
cop even better any non-commissioned or
petty officer can arrest so basically if
you've got a pantsless drunken General
firing guns into the air a 21 year old
Corporal can take care of him Lieutenant
Pike said that he is being detained and
pending the board of inquiry
that's not really how it works I mean at
this point let's be real he's under
arrest they're going to start a court
martial proceeding this board of inquiry
nonsense is over finished done
he safely landed this damaged Tomcat
onto the deck of the Seahawk what is so
unusual is that Lieutenant RAB isn't
even an active pilot in the Navy
he's a member of the Judge Advocate
General core
he's a lawyer
[Laughter]
did you ever think you'd see the day
when a lawyer was a hero in America
Teddy no sir it's like the late night
fantasy for most military lawyers is
that somehow by some happenstance they
get up from behind a desk and they get
to do something and become a hero and it
never happens
but the fantasy lives on
[Music]
thank you
at least they're not wearing their
covers this time around on the flight
deck
oh God here we go
we're out of uniform are
I'm kind of board of inquiry in Naples
in an hour mace
it's not what I mean
are we seriously still doing this the
board of inquiry thing we are done with
the board of inquiry we're moving to a
court martial
[Music]
sure you won't be needing me in Naples
if he is entitled to still wear his
Naval aviator Wings then yeah he should
have been wearing them the whole time I
get that maybe he didn't do it because
of some sort of like shame thing it's
also not clear with his background when
exactly he stopped being an aviator if
it was during the training pipeline
before he got his wings then he's not
eligible to wear them on the other hand
if he had actually made it out to a
squadron and had earned his wings then
he really should keep wearing them even
if he doesn't fly
[Music]
here
[Applause]
[Music]
you know what they say about gold wings
and a white uniform
[Music]
I gotta say this show rules
some minor hiccups on the legal stuff
specifically what exactly Lieutenant Rob
and Lieutenant Pike's Authority was and
what they were really doing but overall
I give Jags pilot episode a grade of a
minus for legal accuracy and I also just
have to say the military accuracy was
pretty darn good too you don't find that
often both legal and Military accuracy
so substantial credit to the writers the
military advisors who helped out it was
just a good episode and I recommend it
to everyone now of course the military
has all kinds of ways to protect their
information but unfortunately for most
of us we don't have military grade
technology to protect our data and a lot
of our personal information has already
been gathered online but you can get
your online personal data taken down
with day sponsor in cogni now I don't
know about you but I've seen a huge
uptick in the amount of spam that I'm
getting and it's no surprise why every
year the number and scope of data
breaches worldwide is rising and you
might not know it but there are hundreds
of data Brokers out there that possess
and sell your personal information and
their numbers grow every year these data
Brokers might have a whole Shadow
profile on you including your name your
address phone numbers shopping habits
and even your social security number all
up for the highest bidder and at best
this leads to scam calls and at worst
identity theft and doxing but that's
where incogni comes in incognitive
fights on your behalf to remove your
personal data from data Brokers and
deals with any objections from their
side all you have to do is create an
account and give them approval to work
on your behalf incognity conducts
repeated ongoing removals because even
if the data broker removes your data
once they can collect it again which is
just dumb but also terrifying but in
cognitive make sure your personal
information stays off the market for
good you can see when incogni does this
on your personal dashboard this is mine
and it shows these sites had data on me
that was rated 10 out of 10 on incogny's
sensitivity scale those Brokers had data
including my contacts financial data and
Health Data now thankfully incogni tells
me when the removal requests are
complete so I can breathe easy it's
terrifying to see exactly how many
Brokers have my data but it's really fun
to watch incognitive get them to delete
that info one by one so if you'd like to
give Incognito try click on the link
below to get 60 off in cogni when you
use the code legal eagle again to get an
exclusive 60 off discount just click on
link that's on screen right now or down
in the description and use the code
legal eagle after that click on this box
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you in court